in my time here on reddit
I've enjoyed countless ghost stories
about haunted houses and so forth that's
all they ever were though just stories
my mother passed away recently and while
some of my relatives and I were cleaning
out her attic I came across my old
journal and I wish that I hadn't what
happened all those years ago it all came
flooding back through the dusty
weathered pages of an old notebook the
memories of so long ago were dead and
buried and I would have preferred they
stayed that way
it was around 20 years ago now I was
only a summer away from putting the
whole North American land mass between
me and my podunk little town the
starlight resort a quaint hotel in my
town popular with honeymooners looking
for a romantic getaway and an old-timey
colonial experience was the perfect
opportunity for me to save up the last
little bit of money I could before
school started I primarily worked at the
front desk for the night shift getting a
job there was a breeze apart from a
couple of regulars the staff changed
frequently unfortunately being
short-staffed so often required me to
step outside of my immediate duties at
times I do remember there was a security
guard who quit after only a day it has
been said that a lot of people who tried
to work there in the past have never
gone more than four or five days without
quitting little did I know that I would
soon find out why anyway this is where
my journal comes into play in my day we
didn't hop on our cell phones and
pointlessly update the world on every
mundane aspect of our lives if you are
working late and you were bored you had
a couple of options be a normal human
being and socialize with your coworkers
get a deck of cards and kick your own
ass in a game of solitaire or make your
own entertainment which in my case was
journaling in high school English was my
best subject and I had planned on
majoring in it in college to either go
into teaching or journalism or something
of the sort so I was no stranger to
jotting down my thoughts and feelings at
this point in my life writing came
second nature and it was the best
therapy that money didn't have to buy a
notebook doesn't lie or misinterpret it
only presents your thoughts feelings and
experiences as you dictate them
I used to write and sometimes even just
doodle if it ever got slow enough or I
wasn't constantly busy I knew of the
hotels supposed haunting and figured it
might be fun to jot down some notes if I
ever saw her felt anything out of the
ordinary at the time the most I thought
was ever going to come from it were a
few instances of cold drafts and some
flickering lights attached below is a
previously unobserved glimpse into the
nightmares I experienced while working
at the resort it was not unusual for me
to jot things down at least twice a
night once before I started a shift and
once more after I got on break to make
things easier to read I've split my
writings into two separate parts per
entry June 21st 1999 who would have
thought I'd wind up here at the
starlight hotel I'm sitting in the lobby
as I write this the history of this
place still lives on through the
atmosphere here floating through the
musty air and embedded in the
handcrafted mahogany furniture and it
seems like the stories about this place
go back as far as the hotel itself
Kevin Macon s'en from gym class used to
always talk about the lady in red a long
time ago farther and farther back
depending on who you ask a bride
committed suicide on the night of her
wedding the story goes that a young
bride having her wedding here in the
reception lounge jumped off the top
floor of the hotel after discovering her
new husband was having an affair legend
has it that she can still be seen
wandering the top floor all hours of the
night her face and dress covered in
blood and broken bones from the impact
of the fall I guess that's where the red
comes from it seems like every town has
their own story about a ghost bride I
can't believe people still fall for that
one anymore
it does have me thinking though all
these rumors floating around about this
place even if they're fake the stories
themselves have to be based on something
maybe there's no ghost but you never
know affairs destroy marriages every day
and as unfortunate as it is it's not
unheard of for someone to fall out a
window or something like that behind
every legend could be a little piece of
this places history piecing together the
secrets of the Starlight hotel might be
fun
well I must take off for now my shift is
starting and mr.
Gilbert the boss needs me June 21st
continued okay so that was odd the time
is 12:30 8 a.m. it was about 20 minutes
ago when this first happened but this is
the first moment's reprieve I've gotten
I want to get this out while it's as
fresh in my mind as can be I was
delivering some miscellaneous things to
a couple of rooms on the top floor it
was just my luck that the elevator
happens to be out of service so I've
been getting my exercise in the access
stairwell the cold hard metal from the
hand railing was at war with the fire
burning in my lungs from the physical
activity I had reached the top floor and
headed for the door when a thunderous
bang sent me soaring out of my skin on
the opposite end of the door gazing
through the doors window looking square
at me was an unbelievably whitish young
woman her face was shrouded in crimson
blood she screeched in pain open the
door get in here now blood on her hands
rised as she slammed on the door
commanding my attention I don't know
what came over me but the next thing I
knew my hand was hugging the handle and
welcoming her into my space she clutched
onto me and started smearing blood all
over my clothes as she whimpered into my
ear where the hell have you been
frozen in fear and unable to answer a
second question came forth are these my
towels it was then that I remembered
room 1307 s request one of the reasons I
had been sent up there in the first
place damn it the woman complained it's
been 10 minutes now she grasped a stack
of towels and pressed them against her
nose the poor woman was taking a bath
and went to wash her hair and smashed
her face on the faucet talk about a jolt
to the system that was an image I won't
soon forget
I'm finally back at the front desk now I
took forever to talk to the woman and
fill out the incident report ok so it
wasn't the lady in red but it was a lady
in red does that count for anything
June 22nd night too here's to you and
here's to an incident free night no more
bloody noses from here on out so far
things have been quiet quieter anyway
I have company tonight someone else is
on duty with me her name is Vivian I
could have used her help last night but
she mentioned something about her kid
being sick with a cold her son I think
and not being able to get a babysitter
you should have heard mr. Gilbert when
she showed up I don't know how this
chick put up with this abuse it's one
thing to reprimand an employee for being
late or not calling in to work but he
was flat-out berating her and bellowing
at her like she was only a small child
he kept going on about how she needed to
take accountability that she was still
just a child with a child of her own she
must really need this job if she's
putting up with that garbage here she
comes now she must have been in the
bathroom for half an hour I think she
was crying anyway still nothing crazy to
report tonight at least nothing as crazy
as last night it's probably silly for me
even to bring this up but I just can't
get it out of my mind I was ready to
write the whole thing off myself until
guests started calling in complaining
it sounded like moaning I had noticed it
earlier when I was running some things
up to the second floor
looking at the manifesto and judging by
the rooms calling in I would say it's
coming from room 209 that's the only
room on the floor that hasn't called
complaining the only problem is room 209
hasn't been occupied in weeks according
to the records there's a lot of Secrets
in room 209 that phrase is giving me the
chills right now that one used to spread
like the plague up and down my school's
cafeteria the story would be almost
completely different by the time it made
its way around the room though when I
saw that room 209 was empty
my heart nearly sank as the various
stories came flooding back to me the
sound coming from the room right now
though reminds me of one particular tale
it was the early 1900s
a young woman from a multitude of places
depending on who you hear the story from
immigrated to America to start a life of
freedom and opportunity with her
sweetheart the significant other came
over first and got a job in a steel mill
to pay for her passage over after
arriving here and settling in room 209
she learned that he was tragically
killed when a fire broke out at the mill
upon learning of his death the woman
became despondent and barricaded herself
in the room hotel staff tried everything
they could but they were unable to enter
the room for ten whole days the woman
sat in the room bawling her eyes out
until finally succumbing to starvation
and dehydration when the staff finally
managed to get through the door her
lifeless body was discovered on the bed
she was still clutching a pillow to her
chest is this what I'm hearing right now
the mournful sobs of a grieving widow
leave it to Vivian to head off to the
bathroom again right now I'd give up my
week's paycheck to have anyone else to
go up there with me and check it out I
don't want to go alone
when housekeeping goes in there to just
clean the room they do it in shifts
never going alone and they're always in
and out no messing around what am I
gonna do I'm just one man the new guy
unfortunately I'm not really in any
position to say no here goes nothing
I'll have to be as quick as the maids
with any luck I should be back before
the ink on this paper dries June 22nd
continued dammit I knew I shouldn't have
gone up there what am I gonna do now
I've never dealt with something like
this before that room was completely
inundated with water how the hell could
that have happened no one said anything
not about this no one should go back
into room 209 I got water all over my
damn shoes and I liked this pair stupid
busted pipe I'm grateful that the damage
was minimal at least mr. Gilbert had me
seal the room up no one else on the
floor reported any issues and no water
got into anyone else's room so that's
good news mr. Gilbert says that he's
going to get some guys to handle it
tomorrow so I guess I didn't hear the
cries of a grieving widow after all just
the wailing of a busted water pipe
perhaps there are a lot of secrets in
room 209 but that'll have to wait until
the room is repaired again June 23rd
what fresh hell awaits me tonight this
has been the most stressful couple of
days I've ever had I guess somebody up
there is making me work hard for my
money so far tonight has been gleefully
uneventful thank God maybe I can rest
easy and just do an average night's work
knock on wood
vivianne came in a little late tonight
but I don't think mr. Gilbert noticed
this time when I went to clock in he
reeked taboos and he wasn't too friendly
tonight either when I told him I was
here he just grunted get to work and
went back to hitting the bottle
I guess managing a hotel isn't an easy
business it takes a mental toll on you I
feel bad for the guy but he could try
and be a little more friendly off to
work I go for now June 23rd continued
break time and what a wonderful break
time it is I finally got to do what my
original job description entails sit at
the front desk and answer the phone I
think I'm a little bored tonight there's
no excitement I managed to get in more
than a few words with Vivian tonight
she's a pretty rad chick once you get to
know her she's a little quiet at first
but all in all a very good listener
funny thing is we went to the same
school but she's a little older than me
by about maybe four or four and a half
years I think maybe she just graduated
before I got there I figured maybe I
would ask her what she's heard about the
place that didn't go quite as well as I
hoped though she just said that she
wasn't much for ghost stories and didn't
go in for that sort of thing I figured
it might be better to just change the
subject without thinking I just blurted
out the first thing that entered my mind
how about mr. Gilbert huh
he can be a real hard-ass sometimes the
air in the room went from warm and
inviting to tense and chilly she glanced
down at the floor what are you gonna do
bosses are crap am i right
true I answered back but I heard the way
he speaks to you why do you put up with
it if someone gave me crap for taking
care of my kid that would be it where
else am I gonna go I'm stuck here that's
all she said just like that no feeling
in her voice
I feel so bad for this poor girl I can't
imagine feeling trapped like that with
no way out it must be hell there must be
something else you can do I asserted why
don't you just quit would you help me I
didn't quite understand what she meant
would you help me get out of here go
find a better place okay isn't this
something you can do personally though
suddenly mr. Gilbert was coming back
from wherever he was that was the end of
that she shushed me and took off for the
restroom she didn't like to be in the
same room with him if she could help it
I was surprised he didn't ask what I was
up to by myself he just asked if
everything was okay and went back to
whatever he was doing he's in the back
office right now I don't think he was
feeling too well
all his drinking must have finally hit
him hard I haven't heard a peep from him
June 24th that was fun while it lasted
but wasn't meant to be I suppose I guess
asking for multiple nights in a row of
unvarying work was too much to hope for
anything that can go wrong has I don't
know about ghosts I have yet to see one
but I certainly wouldn't be surprised if
there's a hex on this place maybe the
rumors from school got it all wrong this
place is cursed not haunted the kicker
was this newlywed couple come running
out of the elevator in hysterics the man
was dressed like the sorriest excuse of
a police officer I've ever seen and the
woman had on a practically see-through
nightgown and undergarments of the
edible variety they claimed they were
sleeping when the wife slipped out of
bed her wrist was swollen like not up
chewing gum and her eye was black as a
moonless night I highly doubt anyone
goes to sleep dressed like they were and
who among us who isn't 80 years old
bruises up like that from falling a few
inches out of bed mr. Gilbert barked at
me to get upstairs and check out the
room as if Vivian and I didn't have
enough on our plates she was busy with
the real glamorous work cleaning up
after someone who came and drunk off
their ass and couldn't make it to the
bathroom when the newlywed couple and I
made it to their room it was just as I
thought an alien from outer space could
deduce that no one had been asleep in
this room the bed looked like a tornado
had hit it the sheets were wet and
stained by the complimentary bottle of
champagne given out to the newly arrived
happy couples and a small dent lay
embedded in the ceiling with bits of
plaster trickling down my guess was from
popping the cork I sighed as I held up
my clipboard and started filling out the
incident report okay I asked do you guys
want to tell me one more time what
happened here I told you we were yeah I
know sleeping
i interjected as I finished filling out
the report to tell you the truth I'd
rather not even know thanks for giving
us your contact information a hotel
representative will be in touch with you
guys in a couple of days I turned out of
the room and didn't look back who knows
what I might have seen had I looked more
thoroughly after winding around a few
turns at the cold narrow dimly lit
hallway I came upon the elevator an odd
mixture of anxiety and melancholy
permeated the air as I waited for the
ride down it was hard to explain but it
was like someone was waiting with me for
the elevator like a presence that just
wanted company and didn't want to be
alone it didn't feel threatening but it
would have creeped me out less that they
tried to give me some sort of sign
instead of just being present I recoiled
in shock when the long standing elevator
door skidded open boo Viviane sprang
forward from the inside and took small
calculated steps towards me this
wearisome attempt at playfulness was
uncalled for there's a time and a place
for this sort of thing and I'd rather
not have the daylight scared out of me
in the middle of a busy shift jeez
Vivian you scared me half to death I
protested I've been looking for you
what's going on Oh what hasn't been
going on I complained I just got through
with another incident report how about
you how are things downstairs that's
actually what I wanted to ask you she
explained do you know where mr. Gilbert
is I was looking all over for him
phones were ringing in the lobby and
neither you or him were there oh great
she just left the phone's ringing to
come and find me mr. Gilbert was gonna
be pissed
as much as I don't like his personality
sometimes I can kind of understand where
his hostility comes from Vivian's a
great chick but she has a real knack for
not getting anything accomplished I
don't know he told me to come up here
and I've been busy dealing with the
wacky honeymooners from however since I
massaged my weary whaty eyelids and
thought harder I think he was heading
towards the kitchen the last I heard I
think a chef cut their finger on a knife
or something and now they got a big
problem this nights been hell she looked
me dead square in the face it was the
first time we locked eyes I never
noticed how beautiful they were before
like a painting one that had faded over
the years and didn't have that look
anymore
these were the eyes of an old soul
you're right she said
I know now we got to get back downstairs
before mr. Gilbert has it in for both of
us no that's not what I mean
I mean you were right before it's time I
go somewhere else find someplace better
it's time he knows she couldn't possibly
be serious she had to pick tonight of
all nights to quit damn it I'm sorry but
this time I'm with mr. Gilbert take some
responsibility and don't just quit and
leave everyone else hanging what's she
thinking June 24th continued Vivian's
gone now I haven't seen her since the
elevator I guess she left I haven't seen
mr. Gilbert for a while I checked the
kitchen thinking maybe he still hadn't
wrapped things up over there the light
was on and the freezer was open a crack
but that's about it I closed up and shut
everything down in there for him he'd
kill me if I let the food go bad if he
had the energy to after killing Vivian
for her abrupt exit on one hand I'm
pissed that she just took off and left
me but on the other hand I'm kind of
glad I inspired her to move on in life
well another day another dollar
I'll miss you Vivian it was nice getting
to know you June 25th some slight
background information this particular
entry had to be logged on separate paper
what I originally hand wrote it after
you read it you'll understand why oh my
god what have I done
there was no one there I didn't hear
anything not a peep how didn't I see
anything there was a horrible accident I
showed up to work today and a different
manager was there mr. Gilbert was found
dead this morning
frozen to death after being locked in
the freezer I've been at the police
station from nine o'clock this morning
until about 8:30 p.m. since I was the
only one at the front desk on duty when
it happened they had a flurry of
questions for me a note was found left
behind at the hotel addressed to me
I must have never seen it last night to
this very day the note she left behind
still gives me chills no pun intended
the original note was kept for evidence
I'm grateful that I had the foresight to
make a copy of it before it was taken
away from me
it read there once was a woman trapped
in a freezer ignoring her pleas he did
not release her growing colder and
colder she could see her breath and died
a slow and icy death despite his crime
of ignorant he had no shame he will only
learn if his fate is the same the sins
of the father must be repaid do your
research and you will find your proof
convicting the one who was ever aloof
you looked upon my situation with much
pity and now I found a way for you to
help me trust what I say and do not bat
an eye this man is certainly not a good
guy
you must strike now it is prime time
hurry and return to the scene of the
crime there's only so much I can do and
the rest is to fall upon you he will beg
and plead and scream and shout but you
mustn't ever let him out congratulations
Mike you spent your time here
investigating legends now you have the
honor of being part of a real one thanks
for sticking around as long as you did
no one else ever would Vivian Gilbert
that was the first time I had ever heard
her last name I had no clue she was mr.
Gilbert's daughter what the police told
me next really threw me for a loop they
were insistent the note couldn't have
come from her because she'd been dead
for the previous 10 years at that time
she and her unborn baby boy rose to
death after she had wandered I used the
term wandered loosely into the freezer I
couldn't believe what I was hearing she
couldn't have been dead I'm 99% sure I
heard mr. Gilbert talking to her it was
all a bad dream it had to be but I
wasn't waking up the police took
handwriting samples and were able to
determine it wasn't me who wrote the
note so there was someone else in the
hotel lobby besides me who wasn't really
though end of journal entries I never
returned to work after that the police
interviewed everyone they possibly could
other hotel guests staff members for
other shifts but nothing ever panned out
most of the security footage was
mysteriously never captured from that
evening just a small portion of mr.
Gilbert staggering into the freezer and
mean nonchalantly closing it up his
death would go on to be ruled accidental
and I would be cleared of any wrongdoing
some of the security footage from other
nights would go on to be reviewed but
never revealed anything new I could
always be seen talking to someone who
was just out of the frame of the camera
in case you're wondering I did look her
up as the note suggested the first thing
that the computer spit back out at me
was an old news article about a young
pregnant woman found dead after a
suspicious accident at the starlight
hotel it was even a picture attached
distressing as it may be I recognized
the person in the photo all too well and
I think I inadvertently helped her
condemn her father to the same fate that
she had suffered by his hand
in order to take that train said Colonel
levering sitting in the Waldo for story
a hotel you will have to remain nearly
all night in Atlanta that is a fine city
but I advise you not to put up at the
Breathitt house one of the principal
hotels
it's an old wooden building in urgent
need of repairs there are breaches in
the walls that you could throw a cat
through the bedrooms have no locks on
the doors no furniture but a single
chair in each and a bedstead without
bedding just a mattress even these
meager accommodations you cannot be sure
that you will have in monopoly you must
take your chance of being stowed in with
a lot of others sir it is a most
abominable hotel the night that I passed
in it was an uncomfortable night I got
in late and was shown to my room on the
ground floor by an apologetic night
clerk with a tallow candle which he
considerately left with me I was worn
out by two days and a night of hard
railway travel and had not entirely
recovered from a gunshot wound in the
head received in an altercation rather
than look for better quarters I lay down
on the mattress without removing my
clothing and fell asleep along toward
morning I awoke the moon had risen and
was shining in at the uncurtained window
illuminating the room with a soft bluish
light which seemed somehow a bit spooky
though I dare say it had no uncommon
quality all moonlight is that way if he
will observe it imagine my surprise and
indignation when I saw the floor
occupied by at least a dozen other
lodgers i sat up earnestly damning the
management of that unthinkable Hotel and
was about to spring from the bed to go
and make trouble for the night clerk him
of the apologetic manner in the tallow
candle when something in the situation
affected me with a strange in
disposition to move I suppose I was what
a story writer might call frozen with
terror for those men were obviously all
dead they lay on their backs disposed
orderly along three sides of the room
their feet to the walls against the
other wall farthest from the door stood
my bed in the chair all the faces were
covered but under their white cloths the
features of the two bodies that lay in
the square patch of moonlight near the
window showed in sharp profile as to
and chin I thought this a bad dream and
tried to cry out as one does in a
nightmare but could make no sound at
last with a desperate effort I threw my
feet to the floor and passing between
the two rows of clouded faces and the
two bodies that lay nearest the door I
escaped from the infernal place and ran
to the office the night clerk was there
behind the desk sitting in the dim light
of another tallow candle just sitting
and staring he did not rise my abrupt
entrance produced no effect upon him
though I must have looked a veritable
corpse myself it occurred to me then
that I had not before really observed
the fellow he was a little chap with a
colorless face and the whitest blankest
eyes I ever saw he had no more
expression than the back of my hand his
clothing was a dirty grey damn you I
said what do you mean just the same I
was shaking like a leaf in the wind and
did not recognize my own voice the night
clerk Rose bowed apologetically and well
he was no longer there and at that
moment I felt a hand laid upon my
shoulder from behind just fancy that if
you can unspeakably frightened I turned
and saw a portly kind face gentlemen who
asked what's the matter my friend I was
not long and telling him but before I
made an end of it he went pale himself
see here he said are you telling the
truth I had now got myself in hand and
terror had given place to indignation if
you dare to doubt it I said I'll hammer
the life out of you no he replied don't
do that
just sit down till I tell you this is
not a hotel
it used to be afterward it was a
hospital now it is unoccupied awaiting a
tenant the room that you mentioned was
the dead room there were always plenty
of dead the fellow that you call the
night clerk used to be that but later he
booked the patients as they were brought
in I don't understand his being here
he's been dead a few weeks and who are
you I blurted out oh I look after the
premises I happened to be passing just
now and seeing a light in here came in
to investigate let us have a look into
that room he added lifting the
sputtering candle from the desk I'll see
you at the devil first said I bolting
out of the door under the street
sir that Breathitt house in Atlanta is a
beastly place don't you stop there
god forbid your account of it certainly
does not suggest comfort by the way
colonel when did all of that occur in
September 1864 shortly after the siege I
recently got a job at a hotel downtown
from where I live I've never worked in
the hotel industry before so I had no
idea what to expect the time between
applying for the job and being hired was
less than 24 hours which made me nervous
but I had been looking for several
months and couldn't find anything so I
thought I'd take a chance this hotel is
about 150 years old and has plenty of
character behind the front desk there
are places where the wallpaper is torn
away revealing the psychedelic wallpaper
from what I can only guess to me the
1970s we're talking bright pink neon
green hookah induced vision type of
wallpaper the walls in the upper floors
are painted bright orange and yellow and
the hallways are narrow enough to give
off a shining kind of feel to it but
I'll elaborate on that later my manager
is a young Chinese man in his mid 20s
only five years older than me the man
who owns the building is also Chinese
the owner is friendly and kind to the
employees but he's also rich enough that
he doesn't really care if the hotel
isn't up to par I learned recently that
he also owns one of the more rundown
shopping centers downtown so this might
explain the less than five-star quality
of the hotel probably about three and a
half star in my opinion some people
describe the place as quaint unique full
of character while others describe it as
outdated or disappointing as a history
enthusiast I would agree that the place
is full of character but I also think
the owner should be a little more
concerned about keeping the place clean
there are lots of problems in this hotel
including mice broken toilets falling
ceiling tiles leaks and other
maintenance nightmares the fancier rooms
on the upper floors have real fireplaces
in them so that adds the risk of fires
at the hand of careless guests mice are
a common problem
and I'm thankful the guests don't have
to see all the dusty traps filled with
dead rodents in the basement but by far
the most interesting aspect of the hotel
is that it's supposed to be haunted
there are two ghosts that have been
reported in the building as well as the
adjoining pub next door back when the
hotel was first built it had the
reputation of being a complete dive a
lady now named lady Churchill died in
the hotel and her spirit supposedly
lingers in the haunted room 49 guests
will occasionally smell her perfume or
see her face in the mirror one of the
most frightening stories included
someone opening the door only to have
lady Churchill fly at them in fury on my
first day when my boss toured me around
the hotel he pointed out the haunted
room to me lady Churchill has also been
spotted at the fireplace in the pub
arguing with her boyfriend the other
resident ghost Brady Brady was stabbed
to death on a basement stairwell that
stairwells not in use anymore as it
leads from the street directly into the
basement instead it's used to store
extra chairs and miscellaneous items the
light is never turned on which adds more
of a creep factor my shift is the day
shift from 7:00 a.m. to 3:00 p.m.
every morning when I come in I have to
check the entire hotel by myself in
search of homeless people sleeping in
the back stairwell or trying to get in
through the basement I'm not an
intimidating person I'm a short female
not physically fit and too friendly for
my own good if I did find someone hiding
in the hotel what was I supposed to do
about it
I'm not sure which creeps me out more
the fact that I'm going around looking
for people who shouldn't be there
or the idea that I have to walk through
dark and silent areas known to be
haunted all by myself my sweep of the
hotel includes all four floors of the
guest room the kitchen the back
stairwell the basement stairwell and the
basement to give you some context the
back stairwell serves as a fire escape
connecting all the floors together it
goes straight down to street level it's
always cold and echoey in there and as I
said before full of dead mice when I was
first told about the haunted stairway I
mistakenly thought they meant the fire
escape stairs as they go down to
basement level
the four floors for guest rooms in all
their Overlook Hotel glory are shaped
like a square horseshoe which means more
than enough blind corners where creepy
twins might suddenly appear lady
churchill's haunted room is at the end
of the hall around one of these blind
corners and yes I do think about that
every time I search the hotel there's an
elevator and an interior stairway the
one guests are supposed to use behind
the elevators this old connecting
hallway that basically serves no purpose
anymore in the past it may have been
useful but now it just serves as a
secret passageway that goes behind the
elevator and comes out at the other end
of the horseshoe this hallway especially
needs to be searched for homeless people
drunks or people having sex the basement
is by far the creepiest part of the
hotel to get there you can either take
the elevator or go through the pub and
down the stairs I prefer to go through
the pub because there are some
fascinating black-and-white photos from
when the hotel was first built and I
love to look at them it's also the best
place to see the edge of the brick
foundation anyway the basement is used
for storing beer kegs firewood planter
pots housekeeping items and maintenance
tools among other things it's usually
deserted now that I know the dark unused
basement stairway is where Brady's
spirit is supposed to be I think I'll
try to spend even less time down there
this week is my second week of work and
my boss has put me on the
afternoon/evening shift just so I can
get a sense of what it's like in case I
have to cover anybody in the future
yesterday was my first late shift and in
that time I learned a whole bunch of
things I didn't want to know from the
lady I worked with this woman let's call
her Peggy has been at the hotel for 14
years she's seen all there is to see and
is well known for her stories I've
listened to some of these stories and
honestly part of me thinks she's full of
[ __ ] but the other part is going to
cautiously believe her on the off chance
that it's true here are some things I
learned about the hotel in the span of
one shift the man I'm replacing was not
actually fired for chronic lateness as
my boss had told me but instead for
sexual harassment
the head of housekeeping a man I get
along with very well as a friend of his
the day before Peggy caught a drug
addict reading around in the private
back office after hours we looked over
the security footage and he was
definitely searching for something we
now keep the office doors locked there
were two guests several years ago who
stayed at the hotel and the next day
they robbed a jewelry store downtown and
fled back to the hotel with everything
they had stolen there was a massive
police standoff on the roof SWAT teams
at all there's a news article about it
online otherwise I never would have
believed it the bedrock of the hotel can
be found in the boiler room there's a
slight gap that has been filled in on
the top right corner that connects
directly to the street one time Peggy
came down to the boiler room to find a
man half through the gap headfirst
trying to get in because he wanted to
know what was down there that image
terrifies me in the span of that one
night shift an alarm went off in the
basement the police showed up at the pub
and a guest verbally abused the day
staff over a non-existent shuttle to the
hospital
no not an ambulance a shuttle taking the
bus was beneath him I suppose
and at my bus stop after my shift a man
was shooting up in public my city has a
drug epidemic going on right now
my bus took half an hour to arrive and
when I got off at my stop it was as
foggy as Silent Hill I felt as though I
should be looking around for Michael
Myers or Jason Voorhees that's one night
shift down I have another tonight and
one more the day after if anything else
interesting happens I'll keep you folks
updated I mostly just wanted to get all
this off my chest it's amazing how
different the hotel is after 3 p.m.
much louder that's for sure thanks to
the pub on one side and bar on the other
every one I've gotten to know during my
first week of work has already gone home
leaving me with drunks strangers and
Peggy's crazy stories one thing's for
sure after three nights of this I'll
never complain about getting up early
again
[Applause]
I've not yet met the man in number 212 I
do not even know his name
he never patronizes the hotel restaurant
and he does not use the lobby on the
three occasions when he passed each
other by we did not speak although we
nodded in a semi cordial non-committal
way I should like very much to make his
acquaintance it is lonesome in this
dreary place with the exception of the
aged lady down the corridor the only
permanent guests are the man in number
212 and myself however I should not
complain for this utter quiet is
precisely what the doctor prescribed I
wonder if the man in number 212 2 has
come here for a rest he's so very pale
yet I cannot believe that he is ill for
his paleness is not of a sickly cast but
rather wholesome in its ivory clarity
his carriage is that of a man enjoying
the best of health he is tall and
straight he walks erect Lee and with a
brisk athletic stride his pallor is no
doubt congenital else he would quickly
tan under this burning summer Sun he
must have travelled here by Auto for he
certainly was not a passenger on the
train that brought me and he checked in
only a short time after my arrival I had
briefly rested in my room and was
walking down the stairs when I
encountered him ascending with his bag
it's odd that our venerable bellboy did
not show him to his room
it is odd to that with so many vacant
rooms in the hotel he should have chosen
number 212 at the extreme rear the
building is a long narrow affair three
stories high the rooms are all on the
east side as the west wall is flush with
a decrepit business building the
corridor is long and drab and it's stiff
bloated paper exudes a musty unpleasant
odour the feeble electric bulbs that
light it shine dimly is from a tomb
revolted by this corridor I insisted
vigorously upon being given number 201
which is at the front and blessed with
southern exposure the room clerk a
disagreeable fellow with a Hitler
mustache was very reluctant to let me
have it as it is ordinarily reserved for
his more profitable transient trade I
fear my stubborn insistence
made him an enemy if only I had been is
self-assertive 30 years ago I should now
be a full-fledged professor instead of a
broken-down assistant I still smart from
the Cavalier manner in which the
president of the University summarily
recommended my vacation no doubt he
acted for my best interests the people
who have dominated my poor life and
variably have oh well the summers rest
will probably do me considerable good it
is pleasant to be away from the
University there's something positively
gratifying about the absence of the
graduate student face if only it were
not so lonely I must devise a way of
meeting the pale man in number 212
perhaps the room clerk can arrange
matters I've been here exactly a week
and if there is a friendly soul in this
miserable little town he has escaped my
notice
although the trades people accept my
money with flattering eagerness they
studiously avoid even the most casual
conversation I'm afraid I can never
cultivate their society unless I can
arrange to have my ancestors recognized
as local residents for the last hundred
and fifty years despite the coolness of
my reception I have been frequently
venturing abroad in the back of my mind
I have cherished hopes that I might
encounter the pale man in number 211
incidentally I wonder why he's moved
from number 212 there's certainly a
little advantage in coming only one room
nearer to the front
I noticed the change yesterday when I
saw him coming out of his new room we
nodded again and this time I thought I
detected a certain malign satisfaction
in his sombre black eyes he must know
that I'm eager to make his acquaintance
yet his manner forbids overtures if he
wants to make me go all the way he can
go to the devil I'm not the sort to run
after anybody
indeed the surly diffidence of the room
clerk has been enough to prevent me from
questioning him about his mysterious
guest
I wonder where the pale man takes his
meals I've been absent in myself from
the hotel restaurant and patronizing the
restaurants outside at each I have
ventured inquiries about the man in
number 210 no one at any restaurant
remembered his having been there perhaps
he has entree into the Brahmin homes of
this town and again he may have found a
boardinghouse I shall have to learn if
there be one the pale man must be
difficult to please for he's again
changed his room
I'm baffled by his conduct if he's so
desirous of locating himself more
conveniently in the hotel why does he
not move to number 202 which is the
nearest available room to the front
perhaps I can make his inability to
locate himself permanently an excuse for
starting a conversation I see we're
closer neighbours now I might casually
say but that's too banal I must await a
better opportunity he's done it again
he's now occupying number 209 I'm
intrigued by his little game I waste
hours trying to fathom its point what
possible motive could he have I should
think he would get on the hotel people's
nerves I wonder what our combination
bellhop chambermaid thinks of having to
prepare four rooms for a single guest if
you were not stone deaf I would ask him
at present I feel too exhausted to
attend such an innovating conversation
I'm tremendously interested in the pale
man's next move he must either skip a
room or remain where he is for a
permanent guest a very old lady occupies
number 208 she's not budge from a rim
since I've been here and I imagine that
she does not intend to I wonder what the
pale man will do I await his decision
with the nervous excitement of a devotee
of the track on the eve of a big race
after all I have so little diversion
well the mysterious guest was not forced
to remain where he was nor did he have
to skip a room the lady in number 208
simplified matters by conveniently dying
no one knows the cause of her death but
it is generally attributed to old age
she was buried this morning I was among
the curious few who attended her funeral
when I returned home from the mortuary I
was in time to see the pale man leaving
her room already he has moved in he
favoured me with a smile whose meaning
I've tried in vain to decipher I cannot
but believe that he meant it to have
some significance he acted as if there
was between us some secret that I failed
to appreciate but then perhaps his smile
was meaningless after all and only
ambiguous by chance like that of the
Mona Lisa my man of mystery now resides
in number 207 and I'm not the least
surprised I would have been astonished
if he had not made his scheduled move
I've almost given up trying to
understand his eccentric conduct I do
not know a single thing more about him
that I knew the day he arrived
I wonder when she came there is
something indefinably foreign about his
manner I'm curious to hear his voice I
like to imagine that he speaks the
exotic tongue of some faraway country if
only I could somehow inveigle him in a
conversation I wish that I were
possessed of the glib assurance of a
college boy who can address himself to
the most distinguished celebrity without
batting an eye it is no wonder that I'm
only an assistant professor I'm worried
this morning I awoke to find myself
lying prone upon the floor I was fully
clothed I must have fallen exhausted
thereafter I returned to my room last
night I wonder if my condition is more
serious than I had suspected until now
I've been inclined to discount the fears
of those who have pulled a long face
about me for the first time I recall the
prolonged hand clasp of the president
when he bade me goodbye from the
University obviously he never expected
to see me alive again of course I'm not
that unwell nevertheless I must be more
careful thank heaven I have no
dependents to worry about I am not even
a wife for I was never willing to
exchange the loneliness of a bachelor
for the loneliness of a husband I can
say in all sincerity that the prospect
of death does not frighten me
speculation about life beyond the grave
has always bored me whatever it is or is
not I'll try to get along I've been so
preoccupied about the sudden turn of my
own affairs that I've neglected to make
note of a most extraordinary incident
the pale man has done an astounding
thing he has skipped three rooms and
moved all the way to number 203 we are
now very close neighbours we shall meet
oftener and my chances for making his
acquaintance are now greater I've
confined myself to my bed during the
last few days and have had my food
brought to me I even called a local
doctor whom I suspect to be a quack he
looked me over with professional and
difference and told me not to leave my
room for some reason he does not want me
to climb stairs for this bit of
information he received a ten dollar
bill which as I directed him he fished
out of my coat pocket a pickpocket could
not have done it better he had not been
gone long when I was visited by the rim
clerk that were they suggested with a
great show of kindly concern that I used
the facilities at the local hospital
it was so modern and all that
with more firmness that I've been able
to muster in a long time I gave him to
understand that I intended to remain
where I am
frowning sullenly he's stiffly retired
the doctor must have paused long enough
downstairs to tell him a pretty story it
is obvious that he is afraid I shall die
in his best room the pale man is up to
his old tricks
last night when i tottered down the hall
the door of number 202 was ajar without
thinking I looked inside the pale man
sat in a rocking chair idly smoking a
cigarette he looked up into my eyes and
smiled that peculiar ambiguous smile
that is so deeply puzzled me I moved on
down the corridor
not so much mystified as annoyed the
whole mystery of the man's conduct is
beginning to irk me it is also inane so
utterly lacking in motive I feel that I
shall never meet the pale man but at
last I'm going to learn his identity
tomorrow I shall ask for the room clerk
and deliberately interrogate him I know
now I know the identity of the pale man
and I know the meaning of his smile
early this afternoon I summoned the room
clerk to my bedside please tell me I
asked abruptly who is the man in number
202
the clerk stared wearily and
uncomprehendingly you must be mistaken
that room is unoccupied oh but it is I
snapped in irritation I myself saw the
man there only two nights ago he's a
tall handsome fellow with dark eyes and
hair he's unusually pale he checked in
the day that I arrived the hotel man
regarded me dubiously as if I were
trying to impose upon him but I assure
you there is no such person in the house
as for his checking in when you did you
were the only guest we registered that
day what why I've seen him twenty times
first he had number 212 at the end of
the corridor then he kept moving toward
the front
now he's next door in number 202 the
room clerk threw up his hands you're
crazy he exclaimed and I saw that he
meant what he said I shut up at once and
dismissed him after he had gone I heard
him rattling the knob of the pale man's
door there is no doubt that he believes
the room to be empty
thus it is that I can now understand the
events of the past few weeks
I now comprehend the significance of the
death and number 207 I even feel partly
responsible for the old ladies passing
after all
I brought the pale man with me but it
was not I who fixed his path why he
chose to approach me room after room
through the length of this dreary hotel
why his path crossed the threshold of
the woman in number 207 those mysteries
I cannot explain I suppose I should have
guessed his identity when he skipped the
three rooms the night I fell unconscious
upon the floor in a single night of
triumph he advanced until he was almost
to my door he will be coming by and by
to inhabit this room his ultimate goal
when he comes I shall at least be able
to return his smile of grim recognition
meanwhile I have only to wait beyond my
bolted door the door swings slowly open
you